- [Mark] All right, so what is your name?
- Leviticus Brown.
- [Mark] Leviticus Brown, very good name.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And where are you from?
- Harlem, New York.
- [Mark] Harlem?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how long
have you been out here?
- Since 1991.
I exited the US Navy.
I'm a Persian Gulf War vet.
Been high since 1991.
I have one son
and
I'm from a family of
alcoholics, of course.
I don't know, maybe
alcoholism is hereditary or
I don't know, if it's just
learned behavior, but anyway...
- [Mark] Is alcohol your issue?
- Alcohol and drugs.
- [Mark] And drugs too?
- Initially it was alcohol.
I was an alcoholic from,
well my dad was an alcoholic.
So I just learned some
behavior traits from him.
He died from cirrhosis
of the liver, of course,
at the age of 52.
That was the last time
I've been in New York.
I haven't seen my mom since 1991.
So it's been a long time.
She's very upset with me about it
but there's issues going
on in my life where
I feel that I don't wanna
take them back home to her.
All my siblings and family members,
all of them are back in New York.
Started out as an alcoholic.
After I got out the Navy,
I liked going to bars.
The Red Onion,
the Golden Frog.
Hey, I thought I was a great dancer,
I thought I was fantastic
on the dance floor when I got drunk,
drinking them Long Island iced teas.
But it came to the point to where
I started crashing my car into poles.
Instead of hitting the brakes,
I was hitting the gas pedal.
And,
why, one day I was driving down the street
and I had a 40 ounce of beer in my lap
and schools was getting out, you know?
I reached down, the beer spilled,
I reached down to pick up the beer
and I heard a big thump
(rumbles) like, you know,
and I looked at my rear view mirror,
I saw a lady laying in
the middle of the street.
I stomped on the gas pedal
and broke the windshield, just ran,
and just threw the bottle away,
bought some gum,
thought about it for a second.
And I thought maybe
it would be difficult for
me to live with myself
not knowing what had
happened to this person.
I went back to the scene
and it was a teacher.
She had just retired that day
and they had a retirement celebration
for her and everything.
But she wasn't hurt that bad.
She just had some scuffs and bruises
and she was all right.
I felt better about it
but still lo and behold I still got a DUI.
DUI number one.
After DUI number one,
I went to school,
did all the work that I did in the school.
At the school, continued
to drink of course.
Even going to school, continued to drink.
I got another DUI, DUI number two.
This was in Long Beach after my wife,
my son's mom decided that
my drinking was a problem
and that I should go to rehab,
rehab number one.
I sit thinking about I've been
to about 15 rehabs by now.
I know AA,
NA, CA.
I can quote scriptures
from any of those books.
I know the Bible very well.
My name is the third book in
the Old Testament, Leviticus.
- [Mark] (laughs) Right.
- So,
you know, of course I'm
well learned in that area.
But one day I was
introduced to crack cocaine.
I had a friend and he said,
"Levi, you getting drunk and
throwing up all over the place.
"Are you really having a good time?"
I said, "Man, just hell
with double hangovers.
"I'm barely getting to work
"and when I get to work I can't work."
He said, "Come on.
"Let's go over this girl's house
"and try something different."
So we go to this girl's house,
nice looking female I would think.
And we went in the back, he said,
"Levi, come on, come on in the back room."
And I said, "What's that?" "That's crack."
I said, "Hell no.
"I'm Harlem, New York man.
"I lived in the projects all my life, man.
"It was rough growing up in the projects,
"the 14th floor, you know,
"poor lifestyle, welfare you know.
"I know about that crack stuff.
"I'm not gonna (mumbles) it,
I don't wanna mess with it."
"Try it, just try it."
So anyway,
I tried it
and the girl started performing
some fellatio, of course,
on me and Lamar.
It was grandtastic,
I arrived at my new drug now.
From 1993
to the present day,
my cocaine has been a problem in my life.
So what happens?
I was an engineer in the Navy of course.
Had unlimited steam engineers license,
universal EPA certification,
so I worked at power plants, RCO.
I worked at
Stewart & Stevenson, a cogen plant.
Very good regular money,
Department of Public
Works, stationary engineer.
Very good money.
However payday would come.
When payday would come
I would no call, no show at work.
What's going on with Levi?
Hey, you know what,
I had my heart,
my chest started hurting bad,
going to the hospital.
Well, couldn't you have just called Levi.
I could have, but I didn't.
I just didn't.
Okay, they would let it slide of course.
But this began to be
repetitious of course.
Pay day after pay day,
everyday after payday Levi
wouldn't show up to work
or he wouldn't call.
So,
drop him, one gone.
Department of Public Works gone.
Every job that I've had
and I believe I was very
good at what I was doing
because they were hiring
me back to back I mean.
I would go to the interviews
and we'd start asking me questions
I would name all these
different pieces of equipment,
how I worked in,
I would talk about
different laboratory tests
we would perform on boiler
water and salt water
in all these different systems.
So they knew I was very
well learned (coughs)
in the job.
They would then give me a chance.
But same thing would happen.
From 1993 to 2007
I must've had like 30 jobs.
They kept hiring me.
Of course became homeless.
I became homeless in downtown Long Beach.
My families got tired of me calling
and asking for money all the time.
What's going on with you.
Okay, you on drugs?
We the hell ain't gonna give
you any money anymore, Levi.
We're not, we're very dis,
you need to come home.
No, I can't come home.
I'm skinny.
I'm on crack.
I don't have any money.
I don't wanna go back home.
I'll probably just ruin your life.
Didn't go home, ended
up sleeping in missions,
cardboard boxes,
downtown Long Beach,
getting arrested for
possession of crack cocaine,
in and out of jail for crack cocaine.
One day, my wife, before
she actually left,
she said that,
"I can't deal with it anymore Levi.
"I just can't."
I would be outside the townhouse apartment
and call and say, "Hey baby,
"I got a flat tire and I'm
on so-and-so-and-so street,
"can you come over here and help me?"
And as soon as she would go,
Levi would watch her leave the house,
and soon as she would leave the house,
I'd run in there, take the VCR, DVD player
or take whatever little
money that I had or thing
and then she'd yell, "Levi you took."
"Look baby, look, I got a job.
"I'll replace it when I get paid."
(exhales loudly)
It came to a point where she's just,
"I can't do it anymore.
"Your losing your jobs.
"You have no income now.
"I'm tired of carrying
you from payday to payday.
"You just won't go to meetings.
"You're just, you're
going in and out of rehab.
"From the VA rehab to
the Salvation Army rehab
"to this rehab and that rehab.
"You still won't do right."
So,
my son now is 26 years old.
I still pay child support
because what happened was
she took the income that I was getting
during the times I was working
and took it to court.
And of course I was
somewhere smoking crack
so I didn't report to court.
So they gave her whatever money
that they felt was necessary
for her to take care of the child.
By the time I found out about it
I was $60,000 in the hole
in child care services.
So,
I owed it to her, not to
the County cause she worked,
she had a very good job.
She's a social worker by the way,
with the Department of Social Services.
60,000 in the hole.
So as of this day, I'm
still paying child support.
Haven't seen my son in years
and
that bothers me also.
- [Mark] How old is your son?
- He's 26 now.
And I haven't seen him in like 10 years
and it bothers me he graduated high school
and you know,
no communication whatsoever.
No communication with
the mother whatsoever.
I find myself now downtown,
homeless at the age of 50.
My income?
A pretty good income.
I get a VA pension of $3,000 a month
and a social security
disability income of $1,500.
And you know what, by the
fifth or seventh of the month
either it's all owed out or it's all gone.
My addiction is, it's pretty bad.
And what happens is I credit doping.
I don't have the money to pay for it
so they gobble up on me
and I go to loan sharks
and they doubled it up on me.
And so it's a very sad lifestyle.
And I'm really having a
difficult time dealing with it.
My heart is just completely broken
by so many things that's
going on in my life.
Another rehab?
I've been to 'em all.
I mean, there, I don't feel
there's nothing else left
for me to learn
when it comes to narcotics anonymous
or recovery period.
- [Mark] You've been
through a bunch of them.
- I've been through a bunch of 'em.
But for some odd reason or another,
I go back to the substance
that devours my lifestyle.
That takes everything away from me
and I find myself back downtown
craving that lifestyle.
See addiction to me is more
than just smoking crack.
It's the lifestyle the,
I get adrenaline rush from
running down the street
or somebody doing
something that, you know,
that impresses me.
It's a weird sense of enjoyment,
but
all I can remember is that one good time,
that one good hit I had.
That's all I remember
all the other time.
But usually every time I get it
and I do it,
I find myself not having
a good time anymore.
Just doing it because I'm addicted to it.
- [Mark] So you ever been clean?
- For two years at one time.
- [Mark] So what got you clean?
- I went to a recovery
center and stayed there
for a year and a half.
After that year and a
half in the recovery house
I stayed clean for a year after that.
So about two and a half years.
But what has to happen I believe
is I have to stay in a recovery house
for at least two years in the facility.
These six month programs,
these 90 day programs,
they won't work for me.
I need time to really see
what's going on inside of me.
And then you know,
when I was in the recovery program,
a lot of things on the surface,
that I just don't see
comes out when I write,
when I journal and dig deep within myself
to find out what's
really going on with me.
I was raised in a household
where we don't tell what's going on.
You know, dad beat mom up,
no, we don't talk about
that outside the house.
Dad's an alcoholic
and he does all this stuff in the house,
we don't, I've learned
to stuff my feelings
and my emotions and walk
around like everything's okay.
When inside I'm just ready to burst.
And so alcohol and drugs,
it's a sedative
to help me control.
- [Mark] It numbs your (mumbles).
- Right, exactly.
- Inside.
- Right.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- Childhood.
Poor introvert
and bags ashamed,
poor,
we on welfare, I got my
brother's clothes on.
Hey, we need father's pants.
Didn't he have those on yesterday.
Those shoes you got.
That kind of childhood.
Thought I was ugly, big ears.
Didn't talk to anybody.
Did finish high school a year late.
But I did graduate high school
but I was very embarrassed or very
hard on myself and because,
I mean, I felt that I
was never good enough.
I felt that what was going
on my life, you know,
being in the projects
with pissy elevators,
with pissy stairwells
and sometimes the elevators didn't work,
I'd walk all 14 flights of stairs
and then once I get up there, you know
I gotta eat liver or whatever,
whatever the case may be.
I'm making excuses for my life today.
All of those, that's the way that it was.
I wanted to do so much better for myself
that's why, you know, my
brother was going to jail
and all my family
members was going to jail
for selling heroin and crack in Harlem,
which was big during that time.
I chose not to do it.
I wanna do more for myself.
I wanna be somebody,
I wanna achieve some things.
But I felt I fell victim
to the very thing that I didn't wanna do.
It has consumed my life.
- [Mark] Leviticus,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You're amazing.
- [Mark] Levi, (mumbles) think and
they see hope for you?
Do they hope you're gonna get clean
and get your life together or?
- I do.
I do, because I've been trying
to do it less frequent now.
I'm trying to,
I'm gonna go back into another program.
I have no choice because I mean,
I can't figure it out on my own.
And I try to go into my own head
and figure out what's going on with me.
I can't do it.
I need help.
And without help, I do not stand a chance.
I need somebody to help me.
So I'ma have to go back to the VA
and just try to do it again.
But this time don't leave in 90 days,
don't leave in six months,
stay the whole year
and get a foundation to where
I can build on.
(Mark mumbles)
That's right.
And it'll open the door
to the rest of my life.
I mean, everything would be much better.
I wouldn't be homeless on the streets.
You know, smoking crack and running around
with these whores about
to get HIV and AIDS.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah, you'll have
your son back in your life.
- And I'll have my son back in my life
and I can go see my mom.
When she cried, you
know, it broke my heart.
When my mom,
she answered the phone.
"Hey, how you doing?"
"Hey, mom it's Levi."
"Oh, Levi.
"Levi,
"why you ain't come home?
"What's going on?"
(exhales loudly)
Oh God.
I could've,
I had to go do some drugs right now.
I broke her heart.
She didn't deserve it.
(exhales loudly)
Stop.
This is something that I live with.
She's 70 years old now,
she doesn't have,
"I ain't got that much time left Levi.
"You need to come home."
I just pray.
I'm damn praying that things get better.
But the only way things
are gonna get better,
I have to try to do better
I have to do something
proactive to make it better.
I just can't wish to get better.
I have to do something about it.
- [Mark] Exactly.
- That's it.
- [Mark] Get right
back, thank you so much.
- Thank you.